[Musik]
und damit hätten sie kommen heute meine
damen oder er hat seiner 3d vision jetzt
bei jedem mobile man es mit luca video
der fall es ist auch das heutige video
wieder freundlich unterstützt worden von
google play denn im rahmen der playon
kampagne spiele ich verschiedene spiele
auf meinem google pixel
april ganz deutschland erstmalig haben
bei blogger gravel bist du bereit eine
internet berühmtheit zu werden
also ich klicke jetzt einfach mal auf
weiter ich bin eine internet fehlers
nicht ein wegweiser sein alles klar okay
zuerst das wichtigste wie siehst du aus
[Musik]
2000 jahre später ich würde mal sagen
ich sehe so aus net dann lass uns mal
einen namen für deinen kanal finden ok
also wir sollen jetzt unseren kanal hier
benennen
ich klicke einfach mal auf den würfel
und wir heißen aus dem pence ja ich
mache wirklich die besten hosen ich
denke mal aus spaß wieder auf den würfel
die leto wizard kommt noch offen
stiletto grill 102 crusher coffee
samurai ich glaub ich nenne mich luki
bei 4000 und jetzt müssen wir doch auch
sehen was wir uns von der ganzen sache
hier hoffen und ich sage natürlich aber
die famous ich mein luki bei 4.000 wird
einfach der grösste star am
sternenhimmel sein genialer annahme ich
kann ich schon an der spitze der meister
sucht rangliste sehen ja das ist ja
super klicken wir mal auf fortfahren und
da ist die film dies ist dein
schlafzimmer ich meine professionelles
lobbying studio aufnahme was auch ein
schlafzimmer
legt die nicht mit lookeen 4000 an
wichtig einfach mal auf weiter gesagt
lasst uns deine erste episode erstellen
als mein erstes video das heißt wir
klicken rom off start wähler eines
dieser themen ich frage mich welches im
moment am trendigsten willst
definitiv bücher wir also jetzt mal spaß
beiseite ich würde tatsächlich das
nehmen was main kanal am ähnlichsten
kommt und zwar ist das eigentlich
gameplay und pfannen würde ich sagen
aber ich entscheide mich mal für
gameplay weil ich in letzter zeit ja
mehr gaming mache die fehler aber auf
jeden fall wieder während das erstellen
eines videos tippe auf dem bildschirm
muss schneller zu produzieren
ach so ich muss ach so wenn ich ganz
lange dann shahada nach so also
eigentlich muss man zwei minuten lang
warten um ein video zu erstellen
allerdings kann ich auch einfach auf
meinem bildschirm klicken und dann sehen
wir schon beim ich kann auch
veröffentlichen klicken video
veröffentlichen modernität jetzt 100
prozent bonus mein video spiral gegangen
ich leute das war's für heutigen video
sie sehen jetzt dass unsere und ich
glaube das ist eine erfahrung leiste
hochgeht
das heißt ich lebe einfach mal auf ok
luki bei 4.000 jetzt ein erstes video er
spielt einen ein fußballspiel und freut
sich das ist ein kanal hier kannst du
deine videos ansehen und eine kanal
kommentare verwalten denken sie daran
auf dem publikum zu hören und
realisieren was trendy ist okay also wir
haben keine kommentare doch netter blog
würde mir mehr davon reinziehen
glock
gaming video hochgeladen aber das spiel
heißt halt blogger geibel von daher denn
die das wahrscheinlich block m ich denke
auf jeden fall einfach mal auf daumen
hoch
er schreibt was böses das den blog ich
gut gemacht du erhältst immer neue
kommentare also überprüfe sie oft okay
das werde ich auf jeden fall mache meine
liebe vieh großartig lasst uns nun
sachen kauf von unseren video besser zu
machen ich bin eigentlich anderer
ansicht was youtube angeht also klar ich
mache jetzt auch nicht die besten videos
auf youtube
da machen andere leute für qualitativ
hochwertigeren und viel viel besseren
konnten als ich allerdings ich nehme
meine videos seit ich angefangen habe
mit der gleichen kamera
ja also ich bin bei youtube geht es
nicht darum dass man sich irgendwie das
beste und holz equipment kaufen kann
auch ein video mit seinem handy einfach
machen und das kann mega viral gehen und
gut ankommen bei den leuten aber ja wir
kaufen uns bessere sachen für unseren
luki bei 4.000 hier können wir uns
beispielsweise einen level 1 notebook
einfach mal kaufen studie ausrüstung
mache jetzt einfach mal zu jetzt bringen
dir jede neue episode noch mehr aufrufe
ein okay dadurch dass ich ein neues
notebook habe bekomme ich jetzt mehr
video aufruf also das tutorial haben
jetzt abgeschlossen
das heißt ich klicke einfach mal wieder
auf start und wir können verschiedene
videos machen das heißt als nächstes
würde ich sagen machen wir mal von luki
bei 4.000 arbeit in seine kamera rein
und ich drücke einfach mal ganz häufig
hier 8 rappen diamanten gegeben ihre ich
drücke wieder ganz häufig auf dem
bildschirm so dass nicht mal ein video
schneller erstellt am irrsee davor schon
die zeit ablaufen allerdings was ich
währenddessen mal ganz kurz sagen kann
ist wenn ihr selber bock auf das spiel
habt flora gauweiler
wenn ihr ein besserer berühmte blogger
werden wollt als lucchini 4000 es
eigentlich nicht möglich ist aber wenn
ihr wollt könnt ihr obama auf eine info
karte drauf klicken und dann könnt ihr
euch dort das spiel in google places
runterladen allerdings sind wir jetzt
auch schon jeden moment fertig mit
unserem fun video und zwar genau jetzt
das heißt wir klicken auf
veröffentlichen video veröffentlichen
und wir schauen mal was da abgeht
modernität haben wir wieder 100 prozent
und es ist wieder wie reingegangen bin
ich so gut für dieses spiel doch das ist
ein ziemlich guter channel sagt ja
denken - danke auf jeden fall dafür
irgendwelche guten videos über bücher
user mit dem namen chet baker alles klar
nächstes video videowand buch sei also
da geben wir natürlich auch ein daumen
hoch heiraten
ich hab schon am start hat alemannia bei
4000 u/min die kommentare wenn ein teil
der crew seit ich muss die brille
aufbehalten also celtics anders da gebe
ich auf jeden fall auch ein daumen hoch
machen mehr davon sagt turbo gastro pad
zuerst sagt queen bee naja du bist der
fünfte kommentar hierzu ist irgendwie
nicht so ganz der erste da geben wir
aber auch im daumen hoch im training ist
gut für dich sagt er also er will ein
sport video sehen ja und da wo ich
schaue nie das video ich lese nur die
kommentare
kohl wird also ganz viele kommentare
haben wir hier bekommen alle fragen
irgendwie nach büchern und das was ist
das ding freitag gefragt nach ihren ich
habe minuspunkte bekommen weil ich aus
versehen ein händlerkommentar geliked
habe leute hört auf nach likes zu gieren
like wenn du zu stimmen der ist zwar
grün also ich sagen daumen hoch geben
aber das ist ja auch keiner kommentar
also dem blockiert und ich bekomme
minuspunkte ich wollte blockieren blabla
hier nur daumen hoch jedoch ein daumen
hoch wir haben keine kommentare mehr
verfügbar das heißt wir klicken jetzt
mal genau zu meinem job und ich kaufe
mir da will zwei notebooks kaum level 3
und noch
der komplette vierer ohne webcam ich
habe leider noch kein geld für aber wir
machen jetzt erstmal unser nächstes
video und zwar klingt mir dafür ganz
einfach wieder auf start und klicken
jetzt mal auf bücher m das haben sich
einige leute gewünscht dein video
braucht 30 minuten bis es fertig ist
möchtest du dann benachrichtigt werden
ja das dauert jetzt tatsächlich ein
bisschen grips idee nicht mit der leute
ich bin hier die ganze zeit am rücken
und ihr seht schon oben die letzten
sekunden und barmen live video fertig
also klicken auf veröffentlichen unser
buch videos ready modernität jetzt haben
wir alle haben doch und beruf video
gefordert die satzung jetzt nur 40%
modernität aber okay gut müssen wir mit
leben manchmal kommen videos auch nicht
so gute anlässe genauso wie im echten
leben bei mir geht ja auch nicht jedes
video viral bei mir ist hab ich sogar
allgemein noch nie ein video digital
gegangen so richtig warte mal ich habe
total vergessen die die paket
lieferungen zu zeigen okay also es
passiert tatsächlich noch mehr an dem
spiel klicke hier um das liefern minute
eröffnen
sind wir mal hier drin hier kannst du
paket lieferungen verwalten blablabla
wir hatten wir haben eine kostenlose
gratis box also mal schauen was in der
box drin ist dann klicken wir einfach
mal drauf und wir sehen ein diamant und
wir haben noch ein avatar teil drin also
dass unser avatar anders aussehen kann
und das waren die beiden sachen das
heißt die geforderten jetzt einfach mal
ein also das spiel ist auch ein bisschen
komplexer man kann auch seinen kanal
noch bewerben so dass man mehr video
aufrufe bekommt und man kann sich auch
noch andere sachen freischalten die
beispielsweise das ist eigentlich
schneller geht oder andere themen über
die man videos machen kann wir können
uns ja noch mal die verschiedenen
bereiche des spiels anschauen und zwar
mir halt wie ihr bereits die ganze zeit
gesehen habe dass hier das ist halt
unser zimmer unser schlafzimmer aufnahme
zimmer dann können allerdings weiter
klicken und wir sehen schon dass hier
ist das mit den lieferungen also mit den
boxen die wir von geholt haben die wir
kostenlos hatten das hier ist mit eines
der wichtigsten menüs da können wir
ziemlich verbessern das heißt ich kaufe
jetzt mal das hier ich kaufe ich jetzt
mal eine webcam
dann haben wir unten noch eine frosch
uhr keine ahnung warum ich eine frau
haben sollte aber kommen die kaufen bei
auch noch ran aber natürlich auch noch
unseren youtube kanal sowie die
kommentare hier bekommen
wo die leute und schreibe neymar mehr
aber sport manchmal mehr über bücher und
so weiter und so fort
die stars dann haben wir unten auch noch
so ein blitz das ist auch ein shop wo
wir fan events machen können
energydrinks kaufen können wo wir
beispielsweise videos dreimal schneller
machen können oder luft werbung also
werbung an einem flugzeug dranhängen ja
also kann ich auch jedem neuen youtuber
nur empfehlen an einen flugzeugen banner
mit deinem namen drauf zu hängen und als
setzen menü haben wir noch die tröte das
ist einfach die kanal vermarktung da
können wir ein bisschen geld reinstecken
die mund-zu-mund-propaganda
beispielsweise erzählen mehrmals
freunden davon und ihr seht schon jetzt
haben wir vier die sich das pro sekunde
an schon haben jetzt beispielsweise
sogar schon fünf und das ist dann halt
wieder unsere aufnahme ist man die
videos erstellen können und da sehen
jetzt auch schon unsere neu gekaufte
frosch und sogar unsere webcam das heißt
in den nächsten videos so liegt bei
4.000 werdet ihr auf seine unfassbare
herzliche fresse sehen
an der stelle ich das heute wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dass
ich mal locker gespielt habe dann
schreibst auf jeden fall gerne und in
die kommentare last einen daumen hoch
bei dem video hier da und meine lieben
freunde jetzt befinden wir uns ja auch
in der endart ihr findet hier ein logo
eingeblendet das ist nämlich das logo
von dem spiel das ich heute gespielt
habe von blauer vw könnte gern drauf
klickt euch das spiel runterladen google
place tor und hier soll noch das letzte
video von morgen man jetzt mit luca
verlinkt habe ich nämlich agrio gespielt
könnt euch auch gerne anschauen
ja ich jetzt